i just want to say i'm nick risco i'm
your instructor for tonight and
tonight's lecture for openings explained
is going to be the exchange philidor
some
that uh people may be familiar with this
opening does pop up a bit more at the
amateur level so hopefully people are
familiar with some of the ideas already
but we're going to talk a little bit
more into black's plans and this is
actually going to be a two-part
video today we're going to be looking at
the the exchange philidor
next week we're going to be looking at
some of the hon ham variations or more
like a
closed uh variations with a
pierce move order but tonight i would
like to start out by going over
a very famous game one that we've
covered numerous times on the channel
but i thought it would be appropriate to
bring up tonight
and this is morphe's opera game so for
those of you
who are sick of this game i am sorry i
thought it would be
nice to go through it once for those who
are not familiar
the opera game starts out with e4 e5
knight f3 and pawn to d6 and this is one
of the ways you can reach the philidor
defense
where black is just defending e5 with
their pawn now over time
white has decided that d4 breaking
open in the center is going to be
the best move here trying to break open
the lines
for all the pieces to move now
another move that i do want to mention
is bishop c4 and this is an
okay move but there are a few um
not problems but a few things white
gives up as far as flexibility
is concerned with bishop c4
which i'm not going to get into tonight
i'm just going to say
play d4 trust me on it d4 is more
flexible
uh and bishop c4 does transpose into
some d4 lines but
if you play d4 first you have some
better opportunities
now back whenever this game was played
this was back when morphe was alive
the the common accepted theory here is
bishop to g4 and this is the main reason
why
i wanted to bring this game up was that
nowadays this move is not so
sound now what is the point of bishop to
g4
well the main point is that white was
threatening to take on e5
and if black takes back so let's say
like make a
random move white is starting to capture
if black takes back
then black loses the right to castle
they lose a pawn
and they're about to fall victim to this
fork
so to stop this idea there's bishop g4
now if white captures black does not
capture right away because
this would just give white what they
want same ideas now you're hitting the
bishop and the fork
so instead of capturing right away black
inserts this capture on f3 and after
queen f3 only now
does recapture on e5 but here
after white plays bishop to c4 there's
numerous threats going on
first on f7 and second the queen is
threatening to swing over hitting f7
again
and b7 now
uh i'm not going to go through the
entire game or at least explain all the
moves
but uh we can see here very quickly
white gets a massive leading development
with numerous
threats um and can get away with
sacrificing a bunch of pieces
uh so if you want to see more about that
game desktop has a nice short that plays
through some of our
tournament commentary i'm sure we can
find that somewhere for you guys
but i do want to get on to the
improvements that black has made
in the philidor so like i said over the
years black has
come up with some nice improvements now
again we're going to see
e4 e5 i do want to talk about the other
move order that we're going to look at
next week though is starting with
d6 and starting with the pierce move
order now here most players will play d4
because your opponent is giving you the
center
why not take it and after knight f6
knight c3 defending the pawn
now black plays e5 and you have a
philidor again but white has committed
to knight c3 so
like i said this does lead to other
variations that we will look at next
week
but a bit more common at the amateur
level is going to be the exchange
variation which we're looking at and the
reason why
is because in this move order white does
have takes on e5
takes on e5 and after a queen trade
black gives up
the right to castle and with the
symmetrical pawn structure can lead to
some problems with black
trying to get a solid advantage a few
chances to play for a win
so uh not saying that here white is just
crushing it's just as hard to generate
chances as black
and so because of this one line some
players may prefer the e5 move order
so after knight f3 d6 we run into d4
now we get to see why this is called the
exchange variation
after pawn takes d4
now here i'm gonna ask the chat what way
do you guys
uh what way do you guys think you would
recapture
if you had this position in a game would
you recapture with the queen
or the knight
see a lot of hellos in the chat nj fan
calibine
de pancho hello everybody
sandra shock is asking how was it
competing for switzerland
in the euro song festival what
i'm assuming there's a player that looks
like me um
i know that when aryantari was uh on the
cover of chess life there were a lot of
people who
uh mistook us okay we see a lot of
people saying
knight to d4 so knight to d4 is the main
line we are going to be looking at
tonight but i do want to mention that
queen takes d4
is a playable alternative not many
players know about this line
uh after queen takes d4 it looks like
you're committing a sin
as far as opening principles go why are
you moving your queen in the
uh in the uh opening you know why are
you moving her so
early why are you moving her to the
center immediately black has
knight c6 getting a tempo on your
precious queen
why are you doing this well there is a
little move here
bishop to b5 pinning the knight so
you're actually not giving up any tempo
here
you do want to develop this bishop
anyway so you can castle
and this does stop the threat of the
night taking as the black king would be
in check
now black's best move here is bishop to
d7 breaking the pin
and renewing the threat of the knight on
the queen and
here white is best just to trade off the
bishop
for the knight now here you do give up
the bishop pair which
me personally i'm not the biggest fan of
but in
exchange for the bishop pair you do get
some
very quick development uh seen by knight
c3
and after knight to f6 bishop g5 pinning
the knight
we see bishop e7 castles queen side
castle's king side
and rook h to e1 and here you could see
white has already developed all of their
pieces
all of them serving a purpose your queen
is nice in the center
controlling all the central squares and
uh black's position while passive is
very solid so
this could stand up but black really
does need to
make sure they're playing accurately
here rookie eight
i think is the best try um i was
checking this out with a couple
databases and the entrance earlier today
i think rookie 8 is the only move to try
and keep this equal
for black and most players here will
play
king to b1 and after king to b1
h6 bishop to h4
uh we reach kind of this starting
position here
and historically according to at least
the mega database
this position has not scored well for
black
but nobody has actually tried any of the
new
engine moves here in this position um
in recent years so i would definitely
say if you're planning on playing this
as black
check it out with an engine there are
some very interesting ideas regarding
pawn pushes on the queen side which have
not been tried in practice
um and according to computers should be
equal
but i do want to mention this is a
sideline
but okay we're gonna get back to the
main stuff everyone was wanting to take
on d4 with the knight that's what our
main focus is going to be on
after knight takes d4 black most
commonly plays knight to f6 and this is
attacking the pawn on e4
and the most played response here is
knight to c3 just developing a piece and
protecting the pawn
and you'll notice white has a structure
very similar to that of an open sicilian
and the only difference in the position
is that uh instead of the pawn being
on e7 as it is in a sicilian
it's on c7 and this does change a couple
things
in our position here um
so all right black to move
and the most played move is bishop to e7
now this is very
straightforward and clear as to why
black is playing this move
you're trying to develop your last piece
in order to castle on the king side
and as far as getting to this position
there aren't
too many other variations white has
um i i can't even think of any major
sidelines
except for this queen captures which if
black is well prepared
should have an okay game and shouldn't
just get crushed right away
uh but after knight takes i mean knight
of six
i i guess you can try and say bishop g5
is an idea but after bishop to e7 you're
not really accomplishing much and this
threat is renewed on your pawn
so you may as well i don't know go
bishop d3 to protect and get ready to
castle
or knight to c3 but i guess knight c3
kind of fails to this idea of capturing
on e4
and then um i guess you're losing this
pawn in the center so i guess you have
to go bishop to d3
that way if there's a capture you can
take on e7 queen takes on e7
and i guess now you have castles and now
the difference is that uh
if your knight was on c3 the black
knight can capture and just trade
but here the knight cannot simply
retreat due to rookie one
so there are a couple um
problems with this line that white needs
to worry about so i just say stick to
the
tested tried and true knight to c3
like i said black plays bishop e7 here
and this is one of our
uh tavia positions
now here there are two main variations
for
white um first i guess
i guess there's more than two main
variations but there's gonna be two
variations we look at tonight
uh in this position white has tried just
about
every legal move um to try
and get whatever advantage they can here
and one of the
moves that looks very attractive right
away is bishop to c4
but this is actually not going to be one
of my recommendations
as i don't think the bishop is best
placed here
after castle's king side uh we need to
take a look at the pawn structure and
this is something that i pulled from
jonathan chance's lecture on the
philidor
um is where your pieces are best placed
now here
on the queen side black has more pawns
over here so you're expecting
more of these pawns to push on the queen
side and
white is expected to push more of the
pawns on the king's side just because
there there's
you know four on three this way for
white and a four on three
this way for black and with this bishop
here on c4
uh i guess black can try something like
um
i guess white should castle first but
black can easily try c6 and then already
you're looking at b5
and b4 hitting your pieces right away
which lets black accomplish this plan
a lot quicker than white can just shove
their pawns up on the king's side
so rather than open yourself up to any
sort of peace
attack like that um bishop to e2
is uh the most played move and again uh
this is not going to be one of the lines
i look at
um the two recommendations i have are
bishop to f4 and pawn to g3
but i do want to make sure it's it's
very clear bishop e2
is definitely playable it's the most
played
and it's played by everyone from you
know
a beginner who just learned their theory
all the way up to the world champions
and uh here's the top game in the lead
chess database is
uh from vishyanand so all the way up to
world champ
but i'm not going to look over that line
as there are already videos that cover
this line on youtube i wanted to cover
some of the more
unknown lines at least in the online
scene here
we're going to start by looking at
bishop to f4 and i believe
that this one has been recommended
online i want to say by
international master levy rosman
or gotham chess i'm pretty sure he's
covered this line but i also wanted to
include it here
so we're not leaving stones unturned
after bishop to f4 one of the main ideas
here
is you are preventing d5 so one of
black's ideas is to get in a quick
d5 now uh i also want to mention
why the bishop is going to f4 so we see
after d5
just knight d to b5 and you're
threatening a capture on c7 and white is
already winning here
um if you go to e3 like we see
in the yugoslav attack or the english
attack
for the sicilians with white trine
castle on the queen side and attack on
the king side
this seems like a natural move but the
problem is after d5 right away
after e-captures and knight captures you
have two minor pieces that are being
attacked
if you let black capture on c3 you're
looking at running into doubled pawns
and if you let them capture on e3 you're
looking at giving up the bishop
pair and if you try something like
bishop to d2
um expecting black
to capture on c3 this actually is not
required
they can castle and continue their
development and
you're feeling a little congested here
with your pieces in the center
uh so uh it makes sense to capture and
after queen captures
um i guess you haven't really
accomplished
much there aren't huge threats here now
all the computers are saying go knight
b5 and you're going to be fine
because you're threatening taking on c7
i guess this has some credit to it
and white should be better off here but
after knight a6 i think it's going to be
very hard to try and
force an advantage here
um so i don't recommend bishop to e3
instead you can go bishop to f4 and just
prevent this idea of d5
because it's going to be followed by
knight to b5 and attacking c7
so just wanted to make sure that was
clear now rather than go for d5
it does make sense for black to castle
and after the castle then white goes
queen to d2 developing the queen again
getting ready to castle queenside
just helping out this bishop over here
and it looks like black has two main
moves here
they have knight to c6 which is
following
natural development we see castle's
queen side
knight takes d4 queen d4 bishop to e6
all this seems pretty natural to me f3
just building up the pawn chain
and then knight d7 and knight d5
now this is an alternative to the main
line which is playable
um i don't think there's any any major
problems here for either side
white does have the space advantage uh
black is a little bit
ahead in development maybe um
and then black's position is just very
solid with all the pawns
together pretty clean pawn structure
very flexible looking at stuff like c6
and d5 to break in the future
now i think bishop g5 is one of the uh
the main moves here trying to trade off
one of the bishops
and after doing so white plays f4 it's
protected by the knight don't worry and
white is slightly better here another
alternative for white is instead of
knight to d5 you can play queen e3
stopping bishop g5
altogether but this is one way the game
can go
instead of knight c6 there's also pawn
to d5
here in this position and this can lead
to some pretty uh sharp
positions um but after knight to b5 i
think
white is going to be a bit better here i
don't see any clear refutation
black has tried c6 in this position but
it fails to knight c7
and your rook is getting trapped and now
after something like d4
attacking the knight well you can go
knight to e2 and then after g5
you can go bishop e5 it's going to take
you a little bit of time but eventually
you're going to be able to
capture on a8 um
see knight to d7 attacking the bishop
trade on f6
captures on g5 and now we finally get to
take on a8
rookie 8 and queen d2 is
one of our positions here this one's
rather equal the only move that
equalizes is knight to e4
but like i said this is one way the game
can go
otherwise black can try bishop to
b4 rather than c6 but here
white has castles long and again you're
going to run into issues with this
attack on c7
if you capture on c7 right away this
actually fails to
pawn d4 uh at least this attacking idea
it's not like white is losing this is
still equal after castles
but uh this attack on the rook isn't
going to mean as much because your
your knight in turn is being attacked by
a pawn
but again this is one way this can go
after um what move is it here after
queen to d2
and d5 right away so
d5 does lead to some sharp positions i
think white does maintain the upper hand
i think it'd be very risky for black to
try and
try and go for d5 that quickly
what if they go c6 right away going c6
right away
is yet another alternative black has
and it looks like there hasn't been been
too much of a attack from white but
white does seem to be better due to
space
b5 has been an idea in this line now
computers aren't recommending it they're
still recommending going d5 but
i was following the database here and
other literature
and b5 seems to be the common plan
that they're recommending and after f3
b4
all white needs to remember here is to
drop the knight back to b1
uh we're seeing stockfish freak out a
little bit here but this
knight to b1 idea has proven to be very
solid
and after pawn to c5 attacking the
knight you bring this knight to b3
and i believe this is one of the more
recent innovations in this line not
recent as in modern
but one of the newer
innovations in the line as far as the
entire theory of the opening has gone
and after queen b6 there's bishop d6
and after rook d8 pinning the bishop
trying to win
there's actually this idea of taking on
e7 and sacrificing the queen
because after this you get your knight
in the center
and you have a rook a bishop and a pawn
for the queen which mathematically adds
up
so you have the material compensation
plus white has a bit more of a stable
position
with this knight ready to come to c4
this bishop if it runs into any trouble
is at least ready to trade itself off uh
the rook is already in the center
this bishop's ready to develop bring the
other rook in
whereas black it has all these pieces
that are undeveloped
currently so here with a more stable
position
theoretically white should be better
here even though they've given up the
queen
okay uh sandra shark is saying bishop g4
you can take on e5 and be slightly
better
so uh i assume that's in reference to
one of the previous lines
um not that bishop g5
let me see i'm pretty sure here bishop
g5
um but nothing's on e5 so i don't know
what you're capturing there so
if you can mention the line then i can
try and go back and mention it
um but okay let's see
yeah and most of these lines that i'm
showing currently white
is theoretically a little bit better
because of space
and uh the bishop pair sometimes black
may give it up
but uh it's mainly due to space and
peace activity
okay the last alternative for black here
is a6 and i think
this move while very subtle seems to
have the best
track record in that after black
castle's
queen side you play b5 now the bishop
may go to b7
it may still try to come to i don't know
probably not g4 because of f3
uh in fact white plays f3 here just to
solidify the center and after c5 is
trying to expand and hit the knights
ah sandra shock was talking about the uh
i guess earlier in the video was the
bishop on g4
on the third move um but okay
uh so c5 hitting the knight the knight
goes to f5
now the idea of this is you're going to
trade the knight off for one of the
bishops either they take or you take
in this particular line black takes we
take with the pawn
and the reason they take is because
they're trying to wreck the pawn
structure a little bit
knight to c6 and pawn to g4 kind of
stabilizing
our structure um now
taking on d6 right away with the bishop
doesn't quite work out after queen to a5
and we're going to run into some
problems after b4 and this
attack on our queen side might be a
little hard to deal with so rather
than take right away just just g4
stabilize
um okay so oops
we're going to continue we see the
attack on the knight the knight goes to
e4
uh not really d5 uh you're looking like
you're forking the minor pieces this is
going to be fine and dandy
but this runs into bishop g5 and you
have to trade off the bishops in a bit
of an unfavorable
situation you just go knight to e4 and
you'd rather them take and undouble your
pawns
and then have an extra possible attacker
with e5
but okay knight to e4 and then
knight to d4 by black just improving the
knights position
now don't get carried away and go c3
here trying to kick the knight here they
actually just have
knight takes e4 and then if fe4
then they can take on c3 and after the
queen takes there's knight b5 and your
queen's getting kicked around
and your king is rather exposed if you
try
taking this knight well your queen hangs
so
don't take the other knight
after knight d4 rather than try and kick
it away
you just have to accept that it exists
there and you can go
g5 try and attack on the king's side
this knight
should probably sorry uh there's
knight takes f3 but this knight should
probably trade on e4 or go to d5
um but after f6 white is breaking
through on the king's side
um i think i also have knight f3 here
just as um
uh an example of what to do if they try
this because your queen is being
attacked
you ignore it for the time being trade
on f6 and then go queen g2
and with the threat of this file opening
and the knights really not having
too great of a place to go where it's
going to have influence on white's
position
this should be uh better the knight will
move away somewhere the rook will go to
g1
or you might capture on f6 it'll be
checked the king moves you take the
bishop
just a few ideas here everything should
come
pretty naturally
uh we see some more stuff popping up in
the chat someone's asking if the
exchange french or exchange caro is a
gambit
no there there are a couple um gambit
lines
in the french and the carl but not in
the exchange variations because you're
trading funds not a gambit
but okay uh so here we're looking at the
the a6 line um rather than go knight d4
what black should play
as an improvement is pawn to d5 and here
after captures on f6
bishop captures on f6
you may end up giving up this center
pawn you don't really want to take right
away if you take right away and rook
takes you're you're hitting this pawn
and there's no way to save it
because if you try bishop to e7 um
it looks like white is just going to get
the development they need
so rather than trade off queens
there's this little czech bishop to b2
and if the king
takes queen to f6 and after king to b1
rook a to d8 and you've kind of
maneuvered your pieces at the bishop
sacrifice
to get this attack on the queen and the
only way to save the queen
or yourself from being being mated
because you don't have queen f3 or b3
is to go bishop d6 and give the bishop
up
so this is a very very active try from
black
to get an advantage and i think this is
probably
um probably black's best
shot at um having an advantage here in
the bishop f4 line
um shoot i just messed up my notes here
um excuse me while i try and
fix them
all right i think i got it so that does
cover
uh what happens after bishop to f4 if
they castle
and then pretty much any move
uh black can try and play for an
advantage after queen to d2
and again i think a6 might lead to some
of the better chances
by black after castle's queen side
b5 f3 c5 knight f5 takes takes
knight c6 and then after g4
going b4 knight to e4
and instead of knight to d4
just going pawn to d5 and after pawn to
d5 i think black is generating
quite a bit of chances they might give
up this center pawn
but it comes with a lot of activity
okay just checking the youtube chat
making sure there's no more questions
coming in
but it doesn't look like there are and i
think that means we can
move on from uh bishop to f4
all right so the other alternative line
here that i think is good for white
is playing pawn to g3 and i'll let this
position
sit for a while and see if people can
understand the reasoning behind g3
uh when you're explaining the reasoning
i don't want to hear so you play bishop
g2 i don't know why bishop g2
is good for this position
why is g3 followed by bishop g2
a strong idea
any guesses
hey i'm clark thanks for joining
adam clark is guessing because it
supports the f3 square
um why would you need to support f3
um f3 is already supported by the queen
and the knight and i don't see how black
has anything that can enter the position
to take advantage of the fact that f3
isn't protected by a pawn anymore
i don't see why that is so important for
black
uh another person in the chat is saying
it prevents the development
of the light square bishop uh
how does it prevent the development of
black's light square
bishop
they can still go bishop d7 they have
bishop g4
there's nothing about pawn to g3 that
stops the light square
bishop's development over bishop to f4
sandro shock is saying a long time
pressure on black's queen side
maybe scoping the a8 rook too um
i think those are a little hopeful
because you do have this pawn on
e4 and you can't just push it right away
because it'll be captured so
in order to really um get
get the scope on the long diagonal you
need to be able to push your pawn
off of e4 and i don't see a good way for
white to do that immediately but it's a
it's uh something to keep in mind
alan jackson saying it inhibits d5 and
the king's bishop doesn't have a better
square
um i can only agree with half of that
um after g3 yeah probably the best
square for the bishop is on g2 but
in the previous position here bishop e2
is the most played move by by
the world class players so i do not
agree that it's because the bishop has
nowhere better to go
um but after g3 yeah the best square is
probably on g2
to fill in these gaps
uh adam clark was talking about f4
earlier
but again i don't see why f4 is very
important to black there's no way they
can take advantage of it
a second defender on the e4 pawn once it
pushes we take the long diagonal
um because of e5 controls the center and
develops on a nice diagonal
after bishop g2 with e5 you threaten
knight on f6
and winning a pawn plus exchange on b7
and 8. oh boy that that one's very
hopeful
um so
adam clark is asking if g3 supports a
pawn on f4 in the future that may be
true
but um uh who was it austin rinaldi
actually hits the nail right on the head
it controls the center and develops
so a lot of you guys are getting a
little too specific with the bishop
saying oh we're just going to play e5
and then we're going to take on b7 and
then the rook
because you're hoping that after the
bishop moves they develop their bishop
and you can just push for free
but you have to remember even if you get
these moves in let's say black castles
bishop g2
bishop d7 for whatever reason if you can
push e5
this does not help your case because
after they take
okay you take on b7 you're going to get
the rook but their pawn
they have a move with their pawn it's
going to take your knight
and if you take their rook they're going
to take your other knight and you're
just
down way too much material in this line
all because
you're getting tunnel visioned on the
idea of winning this rook
so you can't allow yourself to get
tunnel vision to buy these ideas
what's more important is the idea i
mentioned earlier for black is that
black is threatening to push
pawn to d5 and change the structure
and by playing bishop to g2 not only are
you supporting the e4 pawn so your
knight
may possibly move in the future you're
also stopping this idea of
d5 right away as you can just take with
anything either piece is good because
they don't have enough defenders
so this is another idea is it's more
focused on
strengthening your center control rather
than
hoping that one day you may be lucky
enough to push this pawn
and that you may be lucky enough that
they left this pawn undefended and
you're hoping that you may be lucky
enough they left their rook trapped in
the corner
uh does that make sense to everybody i
hope
does so after bishop to g2
we're gonna see black's main plan in
most of these
lines come to light is rook to e8 and
after castles
bishop to f8 now bishop to f8 man
that looks like a weird move what is
black doing they're undeveloping a piece
they're leaving their queen side
unattended
what is the purpose why is black going
for this plan
laughs one of the uh
comments we just got is that uh
everybody in the chat plays
hyper bullet and that's why everyone's
wishing they can play e5 and take the
rook
fair enough okay adam clark is saying
that after bishop f8 they're hoping for
a rook lift
but a rook lift a rook lift to where um
rook to e7 just blocks her queen and
bishop rook to e6 is captured by the
knight and rook to e5
i i might just play f4 and attack it
so if even if you do get the rook lift
i don't know where you're going to be
putting it
alan jackson in the chat absolutely
correct you are pressuring the e4 pawn
and this also can possibly work with the
idea of d5 if white
manages to move their pieces
away from controlling the center d5
might be stronger because
this e4 pawn is under fire
so some of the ideas white has in this
position
rookie one is definitely a principled
move just reinforce your pawn
um again ideas of e5 probably not going
to be coming anytime soon
but i think the most played moves uh we
should take a look at h3
which has been played before and the
idea of h3 is to kind of keep the pieces
out of white's position
and then after c5 which may be a common
idea for black
um knight d to e2 is a move that i've
seen in this position and after bishop
to d7
upon g4 and this is making space for the
knight to maneuver to g3
now any sacrifice here just doesn't work
you're not going to have enough
firepower to make the king if you try
and sacrifice the bishop
it still doesn't work because in this
position there's bishop f4
and this is another thing i want to
mention just about this type of
sacrifice
in general is usually if they can
sacrifice and this queen is ready to
come in
if you can play bishop to f4 usually
that sacrifice is not going to work
as it will defend the square so for all
you hyper bullet players
because apparently there's a lot of you
guys in the chat um
if you're ever doubting yourself on this
sacrifice if you can play bishop to f4
you're good so after g4
rather than try anything fancy just
slowly improving the position should be
black's plan without a bishop c6 and
then i can go to g3
and continue with b5 or
um i don't know h6 is probably good here
stopping the advance of the g
pawn um
so yes h3 is an idea here i believe eric
hansen
has played uh quite a few games with
this h3 idea
maybe not on this move maybe he's played
a little earlier
but um if you're looking for example
games uh
that's the first name that stood out to
me with this h3 id i would go check out
his games
the other move in this position is
bishop to f4 and this again is kind of
stopping this d5 idea not
just because you can take on d5 right
away but again this idea of knight to b5
and forking on c7 is a very strong idea
so
this again kind of stops black black
supply
really making sure they can't push in
the center
now here black has a couple more plans
um c5 is one but after c5
again just this knight knight to b5 and
this should just be winning
for white d6 is a little weak here
um with three pieces on its white should
just
end up winning this pawn the real try
for black here though
is knight to d7 and this is what most
people play
after knight to d7 we see queen to d2
just linking up with this bishop
and now we see knight to e5 and knight
to e5
looks like it's breaking some of these
principles of
openings developments like you've
probably heard before don't move the
same piece twice in the opening
this is one of those exceptions where
it's okay to now
you don't want to print bring this
knight on c6 as this trade will double
up your pawns and might create some
instability in the future you do go
knight d7 to go to e5
and the reason you go to e5 when you're
improving the knight but two you're also
opening up this path for the bishop
again and
being able to open up your lines for the
rest of your pieces is more important
than the fact that you're using another
temple on this knight
because let's face it this knight isn't
great on d7 anyway you're gonna end up
moving it again
might as well move it now while the rest
of your position is still flexible
and now white's probably best move
definitely one of the most played is
rook a to d1
just bringing it to the center onto an
open file
hoping that it will open up one day
and now black has tried pawn to c6 and
white can go pawn to h3
again just removing this square from any
of black's pieces
and pawn to b5 has been played by black
here
and i would say this is probably as far
as
the common main line goes this is where
it really just branches off there's not
a few games here in the masters database
but when i switch over to the leeches
database
okay maybe not in this position with h3
but if we back up a few moves
um there's been a bunch of moves
with this castle's bishop f8 bishop f4
actually i guess bishop f4 hasn't been
played that often but uh it was a move
that i saw in
uh some chess magazine i wish i could
remember which one
um i thought this was a really
interesting idea that should
come to light but okay it looks like
most people play h3
i probably should have done more look
into this position to be honest but
i like the bishop f4 ideas more
so that's what i'm going to recommend
um so okay um that is all of the prep i
have
we're going to open up the last uh 10 15
minutes here open for any questions i
know this kind of cut off a little bit
at the end
um but i do want to make sure there's a
lot of
time for the questions because it looks
like there's a lot of questions on
why black is developing this way so
okay alan jackson asking why not bishop
g4 for black rather than
c6 so i'm going to
[Music]
okay why not bishop g4 here because of
f3
in most of these lines with bishop g4 f3
should suffice
it just kicks the bishop away you can't
actually take it because it's defended a
lot
uh and okay your bishop's probably
better better just going back to d7
now is unclear in this position if d7 is
the best square for your bishop
so playing something like c6 trying to
control some of the squares of white's
pieces
might be a bit more um this is probably
better off for black
trying to retain that flexibility
isn't b takes e5 just winning after
knight
takes c6
um this can't be the line that we're
talking about
is it
ah okay so we're getting more questions
about this f3 move
uh which is fine it's glad we're getting
these questions but okay bishop g4 f3
uh f3 is just the main one um f3 is just
very direct you have to move your bishop
now yes it does get in the way of your
bishop on g2
but there is something else that's
happening here one
you you've actually opened up this line
for your bishop to retreat even just
coming back to e3
and now f4 is a possible break um this
is something that i might try at least
in blitz
uh i don't know about a classical game
um
but okay like bishop g5 here pinning the
knight
if black tries and goes c6 with natural
development
can i get away with f4 here
it looks like i can i might run into a
little bit of counter play from
black with knight c4 and queen a5
but i mean you're you're opening up the
position now and now
all the hyper bullets dreams of playing
e5 is starting to to look like a real
thing now in this specific position you
can't
because the knight queen pawn rook
defend it all
but e5 is now looking to be more of a
playable idea
just because you have this f4 break um
so yes while it may look in the very
short term that this is a bad move
in the long term i don't see anything
wrong with it
you can easily move your bishop out of
the way and push it
if the opportunity arises for you to
push
or sorry to attack on the long diagonal
[Music]
but it was a very good question um how
come ben feingold says never play f3
well most of the time when you have to
move your f pawn it's not going to be
great so imagine
if okay c6 and then
maybe a3 now bishop g4 if f3 was played
something like queen b6 might be a
little worrying because this knight is
now pinned
now in this specific example it
obviously doesn't work because black
hangs a piece but
this is some of the stuff that ben uh is
probably referencing to when he's saying
never play f3
is that it creates another thing you
have to worry about in the back your
mind you need to dedicate more space to
remembering hey
this diagonal is open i need to watch
out for pins i need to watch out for
checks on that diagonal
so rather than risk playing it and then
forgetting it
um and the amount of times you need to
play f3
um are so minimal that
um as a general rule moving the f pawn
might be considered dubious it's always
going to be not always but for the most
part going to be safer if you never move
it
um early in the game
someone was asking after black played b5
so this might be in our main line
so here on b5
okay nj njfan i see your question in the
chat we're talking about the philidor
today i'm gonna have to time you out if
you keep spamming the chat
um so okay austin rinaldi was talking
about taking on e5
um okay so we have
bishop takes e5 this does not
actually win um pawn takes now if the
rook takes this is winning because you
take on on c6 and fork
but after pawn takes if you go knight
takes c6
it looks like you're running into uh
queen b6 here now why is this bad i'm
checking the engines
and it looks like your knight is
actually trapped
right your knight can't go anywhere
so because the pawn can capture
um your knight is trapped you have to
move your knight to f5 or b3
or or somewhere where it has more moves
but if you take on c6 here
queen b6 and the knight has nowhere to
go it looks like b4 is good but don't
forget this bishop is still on f8
so you want to be very careful if you're
taking on e5
and in general i probably wouldn't
recommend taking on e5
with the bishop even though it looks
like it doesn't have anywhere to go
if you can break open and change the
pawn structure a bit the bishop pair
will prevail
it's okay austin it's all good it is
really good to ask
why the moves don't work rather than
just look at the main line and ask why
the main moves work
um i like uh i hope that makes sense is
um
always ask those questions never feel
like you're going to be dumb because
you're asking about a move it's always
good to know why things don't work
rather than just see why why the main
lines do work and
you know avoid memorizing moves
understand the ideas behind them
okay um who was the best players ever
who had the philidor defense in their
repertoire to study their games
oh boy um so you're asking about
checking people to study for
the philidor defense give me like 30
seconds while i pull up um
one of my databases i'll see if i can
get some names for you
that's a good question so we'll do
we'll look at the mega database here
oh boy it's going to take forever to
search
okay that's when we quit chess base and
go back to leech us let's find out
3d6 now if you're looking at this line
of the philidor the exchange
um to do let me switch back to the
masters database
it looks like uh mamadyarov has played
it a few times as black and had good
results
uh his games are the first ones popping
up here if we go back
through to this g3 line it looks like
richard rapport has played it a couple
times
um but it looks like
mommy diarrov has some good results
um buzong z was also a name that was
coming up not you yangi
uh bu zongzi uh was another player who i
kept seeing in the databases
so i would check check out those guys
oh boy chat really filled up there um
didn't tal play it a lot i wouldn't know
about the classical masters i i wish i
had that list for you
um adam clark is asking do i play with
this opening a lot
you hardly ever see it at your level um
so
over the board you're probably not going
to see it as much
uh i don't i i wouldn't think so but i
definitely encountered it
a lot whenever i was playing at the
chess club from my 1000 to 1200
uh rating days um definitely back in
scholastics
you're also going to see it a lot from a
lot of beginner players
because it seems like a natural
follow-up rather than
you know some people who may not know
develop with your pieces first
they're naturally going to play pawn to
d6 because it's very obvious the pawn is
defended so
definitely at the lower ratings you're
going to see it now
you mentioned you're at like 1300 so
1300 people are definitely going to
start knowing hey
develop with your pieces you might be
seeing knight to c6 more
but if you're not seeing knight to c6
and you're not seeing knight to f6 which
is the petrov
then you're going to be seeing pawn to
d6 so this is the other
i guess respectable enough defense
the opinion on it nowadays is that it's
very solid yet very passive
but i would not write this opening off
as something to laugh at you still need
to study it and take a look at it
and then i also see this against a lot
of experts when i'm playing experts
there's at least one expert at the club
who plays the the philidor
all the time against me so
definitely see it a lot um and i've used
it as a
alternative in um some tournaments where
like i
i don't want to play my main line stuff
i'll play the philadelphia
all right looks like we have uh alan
jackson said that some classical masters
who played the philidor was alekhine and
nimzovich
so adam clark was asking what happens
with bishop to c4 here
yeah so i guess we do have a little bit
of time to cover this with bishop to c4
this early now this is still a very fine
playable move this has been played you
know four or five hundred times at least
in uh leeches master database however
i'm not
the greatest fan of this move as it just
transposes into our normal
normal d4 stuff so bishop to e7
now the problem with knight f6 is you
might run into
some knight g5 stuff and then after d5
takes you you run into some some crazy
attacking stuff
uh similar to the traxler or not the
traxxar the fried liver
um but after bishop to e7 there's
absolutely no knight g5 you don't need
to worry
about it at all and now d4 has been
white's best
best tried move here and after takes
takes knight f6 and knight c3 protecting
you've just transposed into the main
line but instead of playing bishop to f4
or g3
you've opted to play bishop c4 and
uh like i was saying earlier i'm not a
big fan of bishop to c4 because
after castles castles in c6
now you're already looking at b5 b4
coming very quickly
and black is going to rush their pawns
on the clean side
quicker than you can push your pawns on
the king side for an attack so
this this uh is enough for me not to
want to play it because i don't want it
to give up all that tempo moving my
knight in bishop
but if you really want to play bishop c4
you can it's just this is something you
need to worry about
playing a4 is probably going to stop
this idea
you'll be met with a5 and you'll still
have a better position because the
development in space but
for me personally that's not where i
like to uh
to develop my pieces i don't want to be
focusing on the queen side this much
i want to keep developing and attacking
you know
so hopefully that answers your question
we got two minutes here for any more
questions
um alawi podcast is asking what about
queen takes d4 knight c6 bishop b5
we already covered that at the beginning
of the lecture um
so i'll go back through it real quick
one more time
but um not as in-depth as before queen
takes is a move
looks like you're giving up a tempo but
bishop b5 bishop d7 to renew the threat
captures on c6 and from here
white does enter a position which
normally works out for them historically
this has worked out for white
but there are a lot of new ideas that
have not been tried yet
that um i'm not even going to put on
stream because someone's probably going
to find a refutation for it
but definitely take a look at this line
that i suggested earlier
um earlier in this stream
what to do after bishop h4 is black
because there are a lot of
really nice ideas that i think come come
from the black side that gives them
chances
um okay cyber shock is
asking about the sheer off gambit is
that a real thing
i've never heard of the shirov gambit
do you mind sharing what the shirov
gambit is
um i'm assuming it would be something in
the philidor
i'm going to google it now because it's
bothering me
oh i guess it is something in the
philidor i guess i will need to cover
this next week
what is the move order for this e4 d6
oh if it's e4 d6 stuff yeah yeah we're
going to cover that next week
with the uh the pierce move order
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're gonna be
covering the hon ham
and uh looking at those variations
because those have
have different ideas there so that'll be
that'll be next week
oh someone said the webcam is frozen
let me fix that i don't know why that
happened
let's fix it
i want to make sure that's working for
the next stream there we go
okay hopefully that's fixed hopefully
it's better but we are out of time
um but yeah just like you guys were
saying uh sure of gambit all the
handheld philidor stuff that's going to
be next week in part two to this uh
philidor um i i don't even know if you
call it a series is two
two parts a series
a duology i don't know what you call it
whatever you call it that's what we're
having
next week's gonna be part two um
but yeah we're gonna wrap it up here
we're gonna move over to twitch for the
winners circle
uh where we're covering smith loves
games from the 1953 candidates and let
me tell you the ones today
the ones today are really exciting so i
would suggest hopping over to twitch
uh we're gonna take a five minute break
and head over there but i do wanna thank
everybody for
coming here tonight asking the questions
um
it's always great whenever you guys are
asking questions makes it very enjoyable